- [Instructor] So last
weekend, my family and I
went out hiking in the desert.
And as you can tell from these pictures
I snapped along the way,
it was a gorgeous hike.
We made our way to this lake
around a small canyon range
and up and down this mountain trail.
Now, all of this was really great,
but there was just one problem.
It got super hot.
And because we were
exercising out in the hot sun,
we started sweating buckets.
And all I wanted to do after
a while was to find some water
and shade as soon as possible.
So finally, after we sat down to have
a nice picnic in the shade
and our sweat provided
some evaporative cooling,
our bodies were able to cool
down without overheating.
So you might be wondering
why did our bodies
in our behavior respond that way?
Why did we sweat and want to find shade?
Well, the answer is our bodies
were protecting us from harm.
The human body isn't able to function
at too high of a temperature.
So our bodies helped cool us
down through a combination
of physiological and behavioral responses.
Physiological responses
being the internal, chemical,
and physical changes that our bodies
carry out unconsciously,
and behavioral responses being the actions
we carry out consciously in
response to what our body needs.
So in this case, the
physiological response
would be sweating, which our body does
in order to cool itself down.
And in addition to sweating,
other physiological responses
were also happening such as,
our blood vessels were dilating
and we were getting thirsty.
And the behavioral
responses were our attempts
to find shade and get out of
the sun and to drink water.
This tendency of an organism
to maintain internal conditions
within an acceptable range despite changes
in its external environment
is called homeostasis.
And I'll write down our definition.
So it's the tendency to
maintain internal conditions
despite changes in external conditions.
So homeostasis is incredibly
important because without it,
we could have overheated
and been in real danger.
So in other words,
homeostasis is necessary
in order for organisms to survive.
Now, you might also be
wondering how living things
generally maintain this
homeostatic condition of theirs.
And this usually involves
negative feedback loops.
So let me draw this diagram for us.
We have our stimulus, we have a detection
and then a response.
So in negative feedback, a
stimulus or a detectable change
in internal conditions
triggers the body to carry out
a response that will counteract
or oppose this change.
So it'll bring conditions
back within an ideal range.
And this is what is represented right here
by this blocking symbol in the diagram.
So going back to my family's hiking trip,
we can say that the
stimulus was the increase
in our body temperatures as a result
of hiking in the hot desert.
Our bodies detected that
our internal temperature
was moving outside of
the acceptable range,
which typically falls between 97.7
to 99.5 degrees Fahrenheit or
36.5 to 37.5 degrees Celsius.
And the cool thing is that,
once our bodies detected the stimulus,
they produced a response to counteract
this change through negative feedback.
We were hot, so we wanted
to become less hot.
And in this case, the
negative feedback loop
caused responses like sweating that helped
cool our body temperatures down
to the acceptable or the ideal range.
It's also worth noting that our bodies
can elicit negative feedback
mechanisms in response
to our body temperature dropping too low.
So if our body temperature
drops below the ideal range
or our body temperature decreases,
then the body counteracts
this change through responses
like shivering and blood
vessel constriction,
all with a goal of
helping to keep us warm.
So negative feedback
mechanisms help cool us down
when we get too hot or they
warm us up when we get too cold.
So they help to keep our
body temperatures just right.
And this process of
maintaining body temperature,
otherwise known as thermoregulation,
let me write that out for us,
it can be seen in all
different kinds of organisms.
You might've seen dogs
pant when they're hot
or spotted lizards
sunbathing to stay warm.
And these are all homeostatic responses
that help keep the
organism's body temperature
within the acceptable
range that we talked about.
Another really awesome example
of a negative feedback loop
is osmoregulation, specifically in salmon.
And here's a picture.
Now, salmon spend part of their
lives in freshwater streams
and the other part of their
lives in salt-water oceans.
So in fresh water, the salt
concentration of the water
is lower than the salt
concentration you would find
in the fish's internal body fluid.
While in saltwater, the salt
concentration of the water
is higher than this fish's
internal salt concentration.
So this means that in fresh water,
the fish will tend to absorb water
and lose salts through their skin.
Well, the opposite is true in saltwater.
Any large change in a fish's internal salt
or water levels could be fatal.
So how exactly can salmon tolerate
these extremely different
environmental conditions?
Well, they also use negative
feedback mechanisms.
So salmon have a negative feedback system,
which detects changes in
internal salt concentrations
and causes a response that
involves either taking up
or excreting salt through the gills
or having more or less dilute urine
in order to reestablish ideal
internal salt concentrations.
And this is otherwise
known as osmoregulation.
So again, we have a
feedback loop that acts
to oppose a stimulus, which in this case
is the change in internal
salt concentrations.
So now we know that homeostatic mechanisms
usually involve negative feedback loops,
but what about positive feedback loops?
Well, many organisms actually
use positive feedback loops
to bring processes to completion.
So while negative feedback
loops dampen stimuli
or oppose stimuli, positive
feedback loops do the opposite.
They amplify stimuli.
And as you can tell from this diagram,
instead of having a blocking symbol here,
we have an arrow to indicate
the amplification of the stimulus.
So in humans for instance,
a positive feedback loop
is used for childbirth.
So as you can see from this diagram,
the stimulus in childbirth
comes from the baby's head,
which presses against the cervix here.
And this stimulates neurons in the cervix,
which send a signal for
the brain to release
a special kind of hormone called oxytocin.
Now, oxytocin is responsible for causing
the uterus to contract,
which as you might've guessed
causes more pressure on the cervix
which sends more neural signals,
which releases more oxytocin.
And this loop continues on and on
all the way until the baby is born.
So when the baby is born,
because the baby's head
isn't pressing up against the cervix
and the pelvic floor anymore,
the neuron stops sending the signal
and the brain stops triggering
the release of so much oxytocin.
So that's how the loop will
eventually come to an end.
So to recap on what we've talked about.
Today, we learned that organisms maintain
their internal conditions
through homeostasis.
And this is usually accomplished
through negative feedback loops,
which dampen or oppose
stimuli as we talked about
with thermoregulation and osmoregulation.
But on the other hand
as we saw in childbirth,
positive feedback loops
work to amplify stimuli
in order to bring processes to completion.